there's no way we could bring this
through the house the Senate expects us
to pass a a bill a piece of legislation
that you just did a great job
dismantling here it sounds like this
thing is Dead on Arrival it does not
look like it's going to pass uh in the
house and here is Mike Johnson the
Republican leader of the House saying
this thing ain't going
anywhere we we did read through it Laura
and it did not take long to realize that
this is Dead on Arrival there's no way
we could bring this through the house
the Senate expects us to pass a a bill a
piece of legislation that you just did a
great job dismantling here what it would
do is actually further incentivize
illegal immigration it would not resolve
any of the problems not reform in any
meaningful way the broken Asylum system
the broken parole process and all the
things that have created this
catastrophe and by the way meanwhile it
further empowers the very cabinet
secretary who designed and created this
mess they don't follow federal law why
would we do this anyway but the bill
itself would actually do more harm than
good and that's why we've said it's it's
a non-starter over here in the house Mr
Speaker are you going to be able to stop
this bill we're going to do everything
within our power I when I say it's Dead
on Arrival I mean Dead on Arrival um we
we we going to have to work this every
other angle that we can and ensure that
we're taking care of our
responsibilities here the House
Republicans are dug in and ready to do
that the point of all of this is
everyone knows it is unnecessary uh by
the way there's $60 billion in this
thing for Ukraine what that has to do
with our Southern border and immigration
nobody knows I just had ran Paul here
who was really going off on that I think
we're going to post that for you uh
tomorrow but yes this thing it does not
sound like it will uh pass well it
doesn't sound like it's going to pass in
the Senate we'll see about that but it
is not going to pass in the house for
sure